given who my dad is i grew up knowing
about the biblical stories but more from
a psychological perspective we never
read them really as if they had actually
happened i think that there were a
number of things that happened that
opened my mind to the possibility of god
my mom got cancer and she almost died at
some point through that experience she
found god my mom's kind of demeanor
changed what she said was she let go of
the control she was trying to have over
the cancer and then this is when things
got like spooky weird she was in the
hospital and she goes i'll be better by
our anniversary and we're like okay mom
you know mom's on morphine you know i'll
be better by our anniversary she went
flew down to the states and had the
surgery and the surgery failed and on
their anniversary she recovered and
nobody understood why it was kind of
like oh that's a weird day and you said
that was going to happen a month ago how
is that possible and she was like god
and i was like okay
not entirely sure how i can logic my way
out of that